[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ولد القارئ علي سليمان النبهاني في محافظه
لندى في تنزانيا والتحق بمدرسه والده
لتحفيظ القران الكريم ثم تنقل بين الخلوات
القرانيه المنتشره في افريقيا ومن قريه
الى اخرى وفي ظروف قاسيه للاخذ على يد
شيوخ القراء قبل انتقاله الى معهد الازهر
الشريف بمدينه دار السلام التنزانيه وفيه
تعلم اصول الفقه وعمق اجادته للغه العربيه
قبل توليه التدريس والامامه في عدد من
المدارس القرانيه متنقلا بين عدد من بلدان
شرق افريقيا
نحن ولدنا في المدرسه
الذي كان يدرس فيها ابي مدرستنا يعني الذي
لم تزل حتى الان
نعم فمن هناك يعني بدات
اتعلم القران من ابي الذي كان يعلمنا يعني
وكان هذه المدرسه
يعني تجمع اولاد كثير جدا
نعم والمعلم
انا مجرد كان ابي فقط يعني
نعم اسم القريه يسمى
ثم بعدما انتقلت من ليندي الى دار السلام
وهناك بدات يعني احفظ القران شيئا فشيئا
كنت احفظ القران من
مدارس يعني ما يسمى الخلوات
ثم بعدما كبرنا شويه
اساتذتنا اخذونا الى مدارس اخرى
الذي يقع في الذي يقع في دار السلام يعني
كان مدرسه يسمى مركز الاسلاميه
هذه مركز الاسلاميه يعني فرع ازهر الشريف
فمن في هذا المدرسه انا بدات يعني احفظ
القران شيئا فشيئا ونتعلم علوم الدين يعني
انا اتذكر يعني
في وقت اذ كان حفظ القران ليس بقوي جدا
الا قد تجد يعني
تسمع مدرسه تحفز القران وهي بعيد
وحال الاولاد كانوا يعني يهتمون لحفظ
القران ويريدون فلذلك كانوا يمشون
من
يمشون الى اماكن بعيد للتحفيز القران
فبداوا هناك ان يحفظون القران وكما كنت
افعل انا بنفسي
كنت اخرج من بيتي صباح مبكرا
واروح الى مدرسه خلواتيا لنحفظ القران
هناك وبعد ساعتين او ثلاثه او منتصف
النهار احيانا نتوجه الى مدارس اخرى ولذلك
كان في وقت اذن حال القران تحفيظ القران
ليس بقوي جدا كما كما كان الان
كنت تاثرت جدا عن
قراءه الشيخ مصطفى اسماعيل
وبعدين محمد صديق المنشاوي لكن كان غالبا
مصطفى اسماعيل
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
[موسيقى]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
ولما بلغ اشده
[موسيقى]
اتيناه حكما
وكذلك
نجزي المحسنين
وراودته التي هو في بيتها
عن نفسه
وغلقت الاب
[موسيقى]
وا
وظلقت
[موسيقى]
الابواب
وقالت
هيت لك قال
معاذ الله
[موسيقى]
انه ربي
سلم
مثواه انه
لا يفلح الظالم
ولقد
همت به وهم
بها لولا
[موسيقى]
ابو برهان ربه
كذلك
لنصرف عنه
السوء والفحش
اء
انه
من
عبادنا المخلصين
واستبق الباب
وقدت قميصه
[موسيقى]
والفيا
سيداها لدى
البيت قالت
قالت ما
جزاء من اراد باهلك
سوءا الا
يسجد
له
الي قال يا ولدتني
عن سي وشهد شاهد
من
اهل
الكل قيصر قد
[موسيقى]
ان كان
قميصه وقد
من قبل
فصدقت وهو من
الكاذبين
[موسيقى]
وان كان
قميصه
قد
من دبر
[موسيقى]
فكذبت وهو من الصادقين
فلما راى قميصه قد
من دبر
قال
انه
من
كيدكن
انك كيد
كن ع
[موسيقى]
ظيم يوسف اعرض عن هذا
واستغفري
لذنبك
انك
كنت من الخاطئين
[موسيقى]
صدق الله العظيم
اما حال القراءه في تنزانيا او حال القران
في تنزانيا
الحمد لله قد اقول يعني في مستوى عالي
الان
طالما نحن عندنا يعني
علماء الكبار
لفن التجويد والقراءات
وما الى غير ذلك ما يتعلق بالقران فلذلك
قد اكون قد اقول يعني مستوى عاليه جدا حسب
تحفيظ القران في شتى مدارس
وحال
يعني القراءه
او حال القران وما يتعلق به
قد اقول يعني في مستوى العاليه جدا ومستوى
حسن الحمد لله اما انا لما قضيت دروسي في
المركز الاسلامي ثم انتقلت الى محافظه
يسمى محافظه تبوره تقوا في تنزانيا وكنت
ايماء هناك اماما
ومدرسا ثم انتقلت كمان بعد سنه
وذهبت الى
الى بلد تسمى اوغندا
وعيشته هناك يعني خمس سنوات وكنت هناك
كمان
مدرس القران
وكنت اعمل في المسجد يسمى مسجد القذافي
كنت هناك يعني ارفع اذان لصلاه الفجر وام
الناس في هذا المسجد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
انتقل القارئ علي سليمان النبهاني الى
جنوب افريقيا مدرسا واماما في عدد من
المدن قبل استقراره في مدينه بريتوريا حيث
الجليات المسلمه من الافارقه والاسيويين
محفظا للقران الكريم
ومدرسا في الحلقات القرانيه التي تنتشر في
صفوف الجليات المسلمه حيث تنشط الجمعيات
التي ينفق عليها كبار التجار حفاظا على
هويتهم الاسلاميه
لما جئت هنا في جنوب افريقيا يعني يوما من
الايام انا دخلت مسجدا فكان هناك ليس فيه
امام فكان الناس يعني
ينظرون بينهم من الذي يامنا
واحد منهم كان يعرفني قال لي تقدم بس لما
تقدمت وصليت بالناس وجاء هذا ما يسمى
متولي في المسجد يعني سالني اسئله
فكنت اجيبه وقال لبس نحن نريدك ان تكون
امامنا لاننا فقدنا الامام فقلت هناك امام
في مثل اربع سنوات
وحتى بعض الاولاد ياتونني في البيت
وادرسهم القران حفظا
وقراءه وعربيه بسيطه يعني
بعض كتب الاحاديث والسير فالحمد لله حال
جنوب افريقيا وخاصه هنا في جهان زبيج
ارى الحمد لله الاباء يهتمون
لاولادهم ان يحفظوا القران
فاراهم عندهم نشاط في ذلك
فيحفظوا للقران الحمد لله وكل اباء وامهات
والاولاد يحرصون على حفظ القران ومعرفه
القران يعني نعم ساقرا الان مرتل سوره
البروج ان شاء الله
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
[موسيقى]
والسماء ذات البروج
واليوم الموعود
وشاهد ومشهود
قتل اصحاب الاخدود
والسماء ذات البروج
واليوم الموع
ود
وشاهد
ومشهود
قتل اصحاب الاخدود
النار ذات
الوقود اذ هم عليها
قعود وهم على ما يفعلون بالمؤمنين
شهود
وما نقموا منهم
ان يؤمنوا بالله العزيز
الحميد
الذي له ملك السماوات والارض والله على كل
شيء
شهيد
[موسيقى]
ان الذين فتنوا المؤمنين
والمؤمنات
ثم لم يتوبوا فلهم عذاب جهن
م ولهم عذاب الح
ريق
ان الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات لهم
جنات
تجري من تحتها
الانهار
ذلك الفوز الكبير
[موسيقى]
ان بطش ربك لشديد
انه هو يبدئ ويعيد وهو الغفور
الودود
ذو العرش المجيد
فعال لما يريد
هل اتاك حديث
الجنود
فرعون
وثمود بل الذين كفروا في تكذيب
وهم
وراهم
محيط
بل هو قران
مجيد في لوح
محفو
ظ صدق الله العظيم
فحفظ القران الكريم يحتاج الى الطالب يعني
ان يكون عنده وقت طويل
ما يصلح لحفظ الايه بعد ايه
وكمان ان يكون له وقت اخر
لمراجعه طويل وحتى في بعض الاوقات في
الليل
فلذلك حفظ القران قد يكون امر سهل وقد
يكون امر صعب
لاهتمام يعني حسب الطلاب لانهم مشغولون
حيانا نراهم يعني
بتدريس يعني اكاديميه في مدارس الحكوميه
اذا قد نجد يعني احيانا نجد طلاب قد تعبوا
لانهم قضوا وقتا طويل في مدارسهم فلذلك
رايت انا بنفسي اني قد نجدهم في وقت
المساء وهم تعبانيين احيانا اذا فالحمد
لله نحن كالمعلمين نستعمل هناك يعني الجهد
الجهد كبير حتى نحثهم بالاستيقاظ في الليل
احيانا فيحفظون الحمد لله وخاصه اذا
اذا الطلبه اذا اهتموا بامش المدرس
كاليقظه
قبل صلاه الفجر ويراجع القران ويحفظ وبعد
صلاه الفجر ثم يستريح شويه ويروح الى
المدارس الحكوميه ثم اذا رجع قبل ان
ياتيني يراجع ثم ياتيني بما حافظ يعني
فيسهل الامر ان شاء الله
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
[موسيقى]
ان في خلق
السماوات
والارض
واختلاف
الليل والن
[موسيقى]
هار واختلاف الليل والنها
ريله لاولي
الالباب
الذين
يذكرون الله
قياما وقعودا
[موسيقى]
جنوبهم ويتفك
روا
ويتفكرون
في خلق
السماوات والارض
[موسيقى]
لاي
ات
ويتفكرون في خلق
السماوات
والارض ربنا
ما خلقت هذا باطلا
[موسيقى]
سبحان
ك فقنا عذابا
[موسيقى]
النار
ربنا
ما خلقت هذا
باطلا
سبحانك فقنا عذابا
[موسيقى]
ربنا
انك
من تدخل
النار وفقد
اخزيته
وما
للظالمين من ان
صار
ربنا
لنا
سمعنا
مناديا ينا
دي
الايمان ان امنوا
بربكم فامنا
[موسيقى]
ربنا
ان لا
سمعنا منا
ديا
انعاملون بربكم
فامن
[موسيقى]
ربنا فاغفر لنا
ذنوبنا
وكفر عنا
سيئاتنا
وتوفنا مع الاب
رار ربنا ام
نا
ربنا
فاغفر لنا ذنو
[موسيقى]
ب
الناس سيئات
نا
وتوفنا مع الابرار
ربنا
واتنا ما
وعدتنا على رسلك ولا تخز
[موسيقى]
نا
انك
لا تخلف المي
عاد
صدق الله العظيم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]